[Música]
enfrente tenía un texto absolutamente
incomprensible no entendía nada no sabía
por dónde arrancar primer parcial de
griego 2 segundo año de filosofía
el tiempo pasaba y yo veía como mucho de
mis compañeros se levantaban a preguntar
al profesor el profesor hablaba y ellos
volvían contentos se sentaban y
escribían
siempre me pareció desleal preguntar al
profesor durante un examen nunca lo
había hecho antes ni siquiera conocía la
dinámica o sea como era iba le
preguntabas te decía todo listo
pero esta vez esperado así que me
levanté y le dije profesor tengo ni idea
de cómo traducir esto estoy
absolutamente perdido y para mi sorpresa
me empezó a decir todo todo
este es el verbo este es el sujeto éste
es el predicado ajá me dije así es como
prueban los demás entonces
volví a mi banco
copie la traducción según sus
indicaciones y entregue el examen a las
pocas semanas trabajo los parciales
corregidos
ni una marquita roja tenía ni una
corrección cuando me lo entrega me dice
karman tiene un 5
pero como profesor si está perfecto sí
pero se lo hice yo
rodolfo son se llama y en ese momento ni
se me cruzó por la cabeza que unos
veinte años después íbamos a estar
traduciendo juntos un libro que nunca
había sido traducido al español del gran
aristarco de samos y no sólo traducirlo
sino también hacer una edición crítica
cuando vos traducido tenés en frente un
texto pero vos no sabes qué tan fiel es
ese texto al original que escribió
aristarco porque el original de
aristarco se perdió que tenemos nosotros
un montón de manuscritos que se
escribieron mil años después y que para
colmo no coinciden entre sí porque están
llenos de errores hacer una edición
crítica es agarrar todos esos
manuscritos ver cuál se copió de cuál
armar una especie de árbol genealógico
para finalmente proponer el texto que
para vos es el más parecido al que
escribió aristarco
y eso es lo que queríamos hacer
conseguimos todos los manuscritos unos
30 y nos pusimos a estudiarlos
miren este es el manuscrito más antiguo
que tenemos de aristarco miren qué
belleza pero como podrán observar no es
fácil ubicarse en el texto no tiene
subtítulos así que empecé a usar los
diagramas para ubicarme
y ahí me di cuenta que los diagramas del
manuscrito son muy distintos a los
diagramas que aparecen en las ediciones
impresas uno de los dos tenía que estar
mal
miren este es un diagrama de una edición
impresa representa un eclipse lunar
el círculo más grande es el sol en el
medio está la tierra y más chiquita la
luna la tierra la etapa la luz a la luna
porque la luna queda dentro del cono de
sombra de la tierra
este en cambio es el mismo diagrama pero
del manuscrito
el manuscrito está mal está todo mal el
sol la tierra y la luna tienen el mismo
tamaño el cono se convirtió en un
cilindro y la tierra la del medio parece
una pelota de rugby
muy raro
sé que todos los manuscritos y todos los
diagramas de aristarco y en todos pasa
lo mismo puede ser que aristas con no
supiera dibujar pero no solo aristarco
lo mismo pasa con los manuscritos de
euclides de arquímedes de ptolomeo y de
todos los griegos
todos tienen diagramas pésimos
había descubierto algo insospechado
los griegos
no sabían dibujar los griegos los padres
de la geometría no sabían hacer
diagramas
ese fue mi primer descubrimiento mi
segundo descubrimiento que vino muy
poquito tiempo después fue que eso ya
había sido descubierto antes hacía ya
unos diez años que había trabajos
publicados sobre cómo los griegos hacían
los diagramas esos trabajos describían
los errores de los griegos pero todavía
nadie se preguntaba por qué los griegos
los hacían así y esa era la pregunta más
interesante como un griego podía ser mal
un diagrama
entonces pensé
los griegos volaban en geometría los
problemas que ellos resolvían con
geometría nosotros hoy los resolvemos
con álgebra por eso nuestras capacidades
geométricas están como atrofiadas y
somos mucho más dependientes de los
diagramas nosotros necesitamos ver la
luna dibujada más chiquita para entender
que es más chiquita pero los griegos no
y si no tenían esa limitación tenían
mucha más libertad para deformar los
diagramas como quisieran y entonces los
podían alterar para mostrar otras cosas
me puse a tratar de entender que me
quería decir aristarco contada diagrama
estudiado el texto miraba el diagrama y
le preguntaba aristarco por qué por qué
lo hiciste así y algunas respuestas
fueron apareciendo
en esta versión corregida del diagrama
se arma un lío tremendo con las líneas
se superponen todas y no se entiende
nada
quizá aristarco de forma el diagrama
haciendo zoom en esa parte para que se
entiendan las líneas eso obviamente
deforma el diagrama haciendo que la luna
sea más grande y que el cono se
convierta en un cilindro pero un griego
no le preocupa porque sabe leer
el diagrama otros podrían estar
deformados porque incluyen algo así como
una caricatura en una caricatura uno
agranda exagera lo que quiere destacar
en este diagrama se quiere probar que la
línea roja que pasa por el centro del
círculo es más grande que un diámetro
pero así no se nota en cambio si yo
corro la línea del centro como está en
el diagrama del manuscrito es más
evidente que es más grande que un
diámetro el de arriba es una caricatura
del de abajo eso obviamente hace que la
línea salga del centro pero de nuevo a
un griego no le preocupa porque sabe
leer el diagrama
este es un mapa de subte proyectado
sobre uno de la ciudad de buenos aires
este en cambio es un mapa de subte mucho
más esquemático lo importante lo tiene
pero para hacer los temáticos tuvieron
que deformar el mapa de la ciudad así
son los diagramas de los griegos son más
esquemas que representaciones exactas
o sea que aristarco no los hizo mal no
él los hizo así a propósito para
enseñarnos algo
estaba feliz con esta idea imagínense me
llenaba de orgullo pensar que había
descifrado un mensaje oculto durante
siglos un mensaje que aristarco había
dejado para mí
en sus diagramas
pero lamentablemente la historia no
termina acá me pasé años defendiendo
esta idea en todos los congresos a los
que asistían hasta que llegue a 1 en
barcelona yo estaba ansioso porque ahí
va a estar un profesor que había sido
jurado de mi tesis doctoral el tipo es
una luz no había mucha gente pero a mí
no me importaba para mí yo estaba solo
con él me acuerdo que lo tenía sentado a
la derecha y que mientras yo iba
hablando lo iba relojeando para ver sus
expresiones
al principio venía todo bien pero en un
momento cuando estoy explicando un
diagrama de aristarco el tipo empieza a
ser así con la cabeza
en ese momento mientras yo seguía
hablando y lo miraba me derrumbé de
acuerdo patente patente que me dije este
tipo tiene razón lo que estoy diciendo
es una boludez
nunca le pregunté por qué hizo ese gesto
pero me hizo falta porque en realidad su
cara me obligó a enfrentarme con algo
que yo ya sabía pero que no quería
asumir y esque
había algo en mi hipótesis que no
cerraba
claro yo siempre había asumido que los
diagramas de los manuscritos eran
exactamente igual a como los habría
hecho aristarco o por lo menos muy
parecidos
pero el manuscrito aristarco se perdió
por suerte antes algún discípulo suyo
habrá hecho copias para repartirlas
entre sus alumnos y algunas de esas
copias habrá terminado en alguna
biblioteca importante tal vez en
alejandría de ahí algún estudio sólo
habrá copiado y lo habrás llevado
consigo a romà que algún romano feo y
bruto habrá hecho copias baratas para
venderlas en el mercado pero algún monje
piadoso regordete y pelado habrá
comprado una y la llevó al monasterio y
los monjes le habrán copiado ahí durante
varias generaciones hasta que una de
esas copias llegó a las manos del rey de
francia que en 1266 se la regaló al papa
clemente cuarto
desde entonces se conserva en roma
excepto por los pocos años en los que
napoleón se la fan o
tal vez
todo ese proceso de copias y copias y
copias era la clave pero cómo podía
testear algo así cómo podía recrear en
un laboratorio todo ese proceso
en historia no se hacen experimentos
pero apenas volví yo agarré a mis
alumnos de la universidad de quilmes y
les dije que ese día en vez de darles
clases y vamos a hacer un experimento
que ellos iban a hacer de copistas
antiguos y medievales que ellos iban a
ser monjes regordetes y romanos feos
agarre a un alumno le dije el diagrama
bien hecho y le pedí que lo copié lo
mejor posible y que le pasara a su copia
al compañero el compañero sin ver el
original copiaba la copia y le pasaba su
propia copia al siguiente compañero y
así unas 20 veces
le voy a mostrar uno de los diagramas
que les di a mis alumnos es de euclides
y explica cómo rebota la imagen de un
objeto en distintos espejos el
observador está en ve el objeto está en
aaa pero la imagen del objeto rebota en
los espejos y el observador lo termina
viendo del otro lado
euclides explica que el rebote de la
imagen forma un pentágono perfecto
miren ahora lo que pasa con las copias
de mis alumnos esta es la primera copia
de la segunda la tercera la cuarta la
quinta el pentágono ya no es más un
pentágono es una casita
y la casita empieza a ganar altura
miren ahora
el diagrama del manuscrito
es igual
[Aplausos]
la copia de la copia de la copia logró
convertir el pentágono perfecto en la
casita del manuscrito
será entonces que los diagramas son así
por culpa de los copistas
elche quien mil veces y siempre pasa lo
mismo les muestro otro ejemplo acá
aristarco quiere probar que el cono de
arriba es más largo que el cono de abajo
pero en el diagrama del manuscrito
aparecen los dos conos iguales adivinen
qué pasa con las copias de los alumnos
primera segunda tercera cuarta en la
quinta o en la sexta ya los dos conos
son iguales y se mantienen así aunque
los sigan copiando hasta el final
y este mi preferido
fíjense como rápidamente en la cuarta o
la quinta copia la tierra la del medio
se convierte en una pelota de rugby
el cono se convirtió en un cilindro y la
luna empieza a ganar tamaño hasta ser
del mismo tamaño que el sol y que la
tierra lo increíble no es que se vayan
deformando sino que siempre se deforman
hacia la misma figura y una vez que
alcanzan esa figura se queda como
congelado y aunque lo sigas copiando ya
no cambia más y es esa figura final la
que aparece en los manuscritos o sea que
estaba totalmente equivocado no es que
alistar que los hizo así porque quería
hacer zoom en una parte o porque quería
exagerar otra no él los hizo bien la
culpa es de los copistas fueron los
copistas quienes copia tras copia lo
fueron deformando hasta llegar a este
estado de equilibrio lo mismo que le
pasó a mis alumnos
la verdad que este giro de la
investigación me desilusiona un poco
porque cuando yo creía que los diagramas
eran tal cual los había echo aristarco
yo era feliz trabajando con los
diagramas porque cuando trabajaba con
los diagramas yo conectaba con aristarco
y eso me lo robaron los copistas
pero sería injusto enojarse con ellos
porque si no fuera por ellos nosotros no
habríamos conocido aristarco
ahora veo cada diagrama como una obra de
arte cargada de historia que se remonta
a los griegos pero que es también una
obra de arte milenaria y colectiva como
esas catedrales que tardaron varias
generaciones en construirse donde cada
copista fue haciendo su aporte con
pequeñas modificaciones imperceptibles y
probablemente inconscientes pero que
llevaron a esta belleza
yo no sé a dónde me van a llevar mis
investigaciones en los próximos diez
años pero de algo sí estoy completamente
seguro y es que
pase lo que pase nunca jamás bajo
ninguna circunstancia voy a volver a
dudar de un griego mucho menos de
aristarco de samos
[Aplausos]
[Música]